Harry and Megan's say they want to swap
financial dependents for freedom so how
much do they get now what's it spent on
and how might they pay their own way in
the future the Sussex is receive 5% of
their income via the sovereign grant
that's public money paid to support the
official duties of the Queen it pays for
official trips like the 81 thousand
pounds spent on a trip to Fiji and Tonga
last year and it also covered a 2.4
million pound refurbishment of their
home Frogmore cottage which is owned by
the Queen now the couple say they want
to stay at the house but will give up
the annual sovereign grant payment
because they want to be financially
independent and taking the money
prevents them in-law from earning
professional income but 95 percent of
their money comes from Prince Charles
via income from the Duchy of Cornwall a
vast estate of Agriculture property and
commercial holdings which he gets as
heir to the throne now last year charles
paid just over 5 million pounds to fund
both the sussex a--'s and the duke and
duchess of cambridge it pays for their
staff offices expenses and personal
travel now the Sussex is don't mention
giving up any of this which is an
interesting definition of financial
independence there's also an undisclosed
cost for all Royals on security which is
covered by the Home Office
now Harry and Megan are already wealthy
he inherited an estimated 10 million
pounds from his mother and Megan is said
to be worth around 3 million pounds from
her acting career but future income will
depend on them trading on their titles
now the Sussex royal brand was
trademarked last year for a huge range
of uses from merchandise and clothing to
social care services and charitable
fundraising now given their fame and
profile licensing the brand could have
huge commercial potential Prince Charles
has already done something similar
selling exclusive rights to the Duchy
originals brand to whiterose and
sponsors would cue up Zara Phillips the
Queen's eldest grandchild doesn't have a
title but she is an ambassador for Land
Rover now Megan and Harry say there is a
precedent for wage-earning Royals
Princess Beatrice and Eugenie both have
titles
and paying jobs Meghan has her own
earning power of course even if she
doesn't return to acting her name would
bring production clout to film
television and publishing projects I
think the real question for Harry and
Meghan given the statement that they've
released is not so much what are the
possibilities but that you'd want to do
but what are the possibilities that you
want to exclude so so where is the focus
going to be and if it is to be around
socially purposeful socially good things
and that will limit the revenue learning
opportunities that they have if Meghan
and Harry can end their dependence on
Charles and succeed in becoming truly
financially independent they might set a
new funding model for the spare heirs
but whether the royal family and
crucially the public are ready for
privatized princes and princesses is
another question